what's up my fellow geek Zaki here back
with another unboxing this time we've
got something special for you
Transformers fan so here we got the
modern icons uh sound wave and Megatron
on top of that we also got a really nice
deal with this bottom icons helmet
display stand now these are game Star
exclusives we got them at the sale and
we can't wait to unbox them so let's
begin now let's start off with sound
wave nice you can probably tell from the
helmet and the design this is more
reminiscent of the G1 Transformers and
you can tell by the logo as well very
classic Transformers font as well and
what I really like about the box too is
that when you flip it to the back
you've got all your G1 Transformers
fighting man
That's So Dope
so if you ever thought that boxes were
boring I mean this is definitely one for
keeping you know instead of throwing it
out now two things about these two
helmets uh they both light up they have
voice lines as well and you can wear
them
because what's the point of having how
many you can't wear them right but
what's very important is the fact that
these are authentic Transformers
licensed toys alright so this is in
collaboration with Hasbro so just bear
that in mind that being said you guys
got a little tour of the box
over here and stuff like that and we are
going to open these up let's go right
in plastic just in case it also comes
with some I guess cheek pads and a
manual so we'll figure out how that
works and if I'm not wrong these Summers
will require you to have three AAA
batteries all right and they are sold
separately of course now look at that
nice Sheen we've got a nice metallic
finish so you have a little bit of some
sparkliness
in the paint gonna give you a photo here
look at that
that's so nice oh wow
like that
check it out folks sound wave so I
really like the paint job on the helmet
itself now bear in mind when it comes to
shipping because we have to ship it all
the way from the us back here in
Singapore so you might
see a little bit of scarves and stuff
like that which I think to some is going
to be a little bit of a pain but I think
for us you know I still keep up man I
mean there's no point returning it back
anyway so yeah just a few Scouts maybe
from shipping and whatnot and yeah
there's one more thing we need to talk
about which is the there's a little like
bubble in the visor but that's pretty
much it
um how do you wear this you don't just
simply uh fit it onto your head you guys
have easy access from the back
Wing wink just to slot your head inside
and if you wanted to know how to access
the battery compartment in the helmet
itself you have to go on to the right
side of the where the ear is and you'll
see three screws and just insert the
three AAA batteries inside there and
Bing Bang Boom you're actually ready to
go now I'm gonna wear this
I don't think it's glass this is safe
it's too big for my head
so I gotta do it like so
and yeah
I think maybe the cheek pads will help
because right now it's just sinking low
so I can't really see I got to do it
like red all right so everything that
you want to access when it comes to the
voice lines and lighting it up it's just
a big button on the right side so
everything's on the right side
and I'm just gonna play a few different
uh voice lines for you to check out
[Music]
all right so cycling through the voice
lines you guys will have five Voice
lines from sound wave and it sounds
exactly like the G1 animated shows you
know so I think they got some sound
bites from that so that's pretty cool
now
the only thing is I don't want to damage
the table too much so let's put it on
the helmet stand alright so this is also
from Modern icons it's all helmet stand
for one-to-one replicas and it says it
can support helmets up to five kilograms
so
that's that's actually pretty damn
impressive I believe this is the topper
and just more parts oh and a very
weighted
base base itself has a weight of 300
grams so that's pretty neat and what we
really like about these um
helmet stance is that it's really so
sci-fi geeky looking what I'm trying to
say so it doesn't matter whether it's a
Transformers helmet doesn't matter
whether it's a Star Wars helmet
doesn't even matter whether it's a
motorcycle helmet you know so
essentially you have a total of
four pieces right and it's pretty much
straightforward find the groove
everything has its place slot that in
bang bang boom next one here slotted
place again boom and then of course we
got the topper here
and last but not least
just Mount the helmet and because of the
rounded Dome actually
prevents the homophone wobbling too much
just gotta find the center of gravity
and there you go
look at that
you do the spin you can
there you go right your own spinning
helmet stand oh okay never mind let's
not do that now of course if you guys
are gonna be wearing it more often then
it comes included with this little foam
pads I won't say it's it's the most
robust but it should help you level your
head like mine so just put two on the
side
and then one on top okay all right so
with sound wave all the way let's take a
look at Megatron but before that here's
a message from our sponsors this video
is brought to you by MSI meet the summit
E6 then flip featuring the latest 12th
gen Intel Core i7 processor RTX 30
series graphics and a 16 inch Quad HD
Plus touchscreen panel with a 360 degree
hinge it lets you unleash maximum
productivity with up to 11 hours of
battery life at just 2 kilograms the
summit e16 flip offers unprecedented
performance and functionality allowing
you to work and play anywhere anytime
woo so same thing pretty much the same
design at the back as well if you guys
were wondering it's got the same G1 like
war going on at the back and
yeah Megatron Megatron Megatron there
you go you guys ready
nice
take a look at that folks
nice metallic brush it's like weathering
there
it looks really dope
brush Metal finish and you get that nice
like 80s animated Style with the
I don't know how to say it but when it
comes to these edges they're brushed in
a different direction
so it really shows the edges a lot more
prominently
so the the brush and the paint job
finish is pretty much what you would see
in the Transformers gy Animated Series I
would say the quality is still this
decent uh again not too sure if there's
some scarves or denses intended or it's
just a shipping thing but for what it's
worth man
hey can't complain now uh also a few
differences here is that the helmet uh
comes with cheek pads as well but you
also get a helmet harness if you will so
you can tighten it up so I guess
Megatron will be a lot more roomy and if
you were wondering about the size
Megatron at the top
this is a tinched toilet because of its
slope at the other side of his head
Power It Up you would access it from the
bottom left of his helmet
oh such a classy Megatron sound
[Music]
oh
I love that one
so again you get five Voice lines as
well
with Megatron I've got a mid man just
brings up so many cool memories
from the G1 site so
I'm gonna wear it now try on the harness
as well
okay clearly my head is too big now my
eye one eye is closed
I might have done something wrong here
I might be wrong I think this might just
be for the kids
because my head is huge
so let's try that again without the uh
the assist
oh yeah no it feels actually just nice
wow
okay let's let's try it on again
that's cool
let's see how bold and light up together
we have another one
yeah let's see a little bit more
all right
you guys ready all right three two one
cool I would say that sound wave is a
little bit softer to the helmet but Mega
try I'm guessing the speakers actually
coming from the top of his house so he's
then again Megatron is really loud guys
so
yeah yeah I can definitely hear more
or maybe that's that's how sound wave
sounds like alright folks so that covers
the modern icons Megatron and sound wave
helmets along with this awesome helmet
display stance and I think that's I
think these Shamus dance are the best
purchase of them but honestly because we
got five of them you know we're gonna do
look at all these wonderful helmets
we've got Boca town and the phase 2
clone trooper from the Star Wars Black
Series thank you Hasbro and not to
mention our favorite Space Engineer
Isaac from Dead Space remake
told you can fit any kind of helmet and
it'll still look good anyway thank you
for watching this video If You Like It
smash that like button smash that
subscribe button and if you have any
comments leave them down below as well
until next time check out these other
videos right here
foreign
[Music]